autre rumeur disant que ce soir est
assurée par philippe katerine pour son
album philippe katerine heures
normalement pour faire chic on dit album
éponyme parce que ça veut dire pareil
philippe quintais bonsoir on peut dire
éponyme d'annie paraît que ça se dit
dans le métier
ça fait chic album éponyme alors donc là
tout est dit sur la pochette c'est papa
maman et fiston ouais enfin c'est un
disque en fait en famille ça vous fait
pour la famille mais par enchantement
oui bien sûr il chante dans le disque
alors ce qui est formidable quand vous
sortez un disque et que tout le monde
s'interroge est ce que c'est la grosse
fumisterie du siècle douce et atic
génial à chaque fois y en a pas un qui
peut s'empêcher de poser cette question
là parce que ça c'est un peu nouveau
avant c'était pas trop on se posait pas
cette question là aujourd'hui une
question se pose
je ne pourrais absolument pas est ce que
philippe katerine est étonné par
l'avalanche d'exégèse très technique des
fois très littéraire ski qui tombe sur
ce cd de cuyper on est toujours content
que
les gens écoutent le disque crise et
qu'ils en parlent et qu'ils écrivent de
sursis ça vaut mieux qu'une vaste
indifférence oui et bien sûr la pire des
récompenses qui puisse arriver
mais est-ce qu'on se reconnaît au bas
après on se réjouit surtout pourquoi je
dis on je me réjouis je me réjouis de ne
pas faire l'unanimité qui fait
l'unanimité c'est très sain un dictateur
qui fait 90 1 % dans certains pays
rassurant je crois ce qu'il ya
d'extraordinaire mathématiques
oui j'ai vu le vent de vent dans les
cheveux gris se sont bien attachés au
maintien
vous êtes se sont jetés sur nous j'ai
beaucoup apprécié d'ailleurs y'a rien il
ya une séquence
le bisou vous êtes également sur une
plage où toutes les filles tout à coup
se jette sur vous et je me demande ce
soir mademoiselle vous qui connaissait
le bisou vous pouvez vous jeter sur lui
pour voir ce que ça fait sur le cloud
rien sinon ils sèment une prise de sang
afin que ça fait pas mal de régis leurs
voilà mes demoiselles suivante les
gentils dévoués dans la mieux fait à mes
fans
non ne soyez pas timide c'est dans
l'eure c'est simplement solaire c'est
sur le clip décalé
il embrasse un garçon d'ailleurs sur le
clip vous le verrez c'est assez lent
bourgend peur on peut le dire comme ça
parce que les cadres est toujours aime
bien l'androgynie bien oui c'est vrai ça
oui moi j'aime bien
oui de 10 est toujours le même alors
dans ce cd on à l'univers de philippe
katerine des mots qui sont répétés
presque des serinette enfantine vous
dites moi vous avez envie de retrouver
cette pureté d'enfance quand vous
écrivez des textes ce serait
très prétentieux de ma part ni
ces convois dessiner un enfant l'envi de
suite parce que parce que la
civilisation est passé dessus c'est fini
déjà peu plus dessiner comme un gosse je
dessine beaucoup de joie des enfants
dessiner jeu j'ai les larmes aux yeux je
me dis bon je ferai plus jamais cette
évidence alors le dit c'est un petit peu
me fait dans cette illusion de
d'évidence mais bon alors très peu de
mots temps en temps ou des fois on a
beaucoup ça dépend les puits
il ya par exemple je vous donne un
exemple de presse que les purs au
maximum juif arabe arabe juif qui était
une des chansons et qui avec ses deux
seuls mots en accélérant le rythme ouais
vous générez une angoisse oui il ya une
angoisse et puis alors c'est le
aussi le fait d'un verset aussi est juif
arabe épouse arabes juifs traqués keaton
à
à penser dans le cerveau est atteint
quand on n'a pas fait sophie ça
s'accélère
ça s'accélère donc on a l'impression
d'une guerre puis dans une harmonie
ensuite fait perdre une part ensemble
français c'est une chanson enfin je me
suis dit qu'il y en ait chansons
peut-être qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
mots je me suis dit que c'était aussi
les mots étaient absents 4e finale super
important autre chose
vous avez fait des clips presque pour
toutes les chansons dont je trouve
dommage vraiment dommage que ce soit pas
joint ses fils sont extraordinaires ah
ouais non parce que le
c'est un peu tôt parce qu'on voudrait
faire pour chaque chanson et un clip oui
on est bien parti avec les grands
chantiers
quand on fait des clips mais à 24
chansons pour faire 24 clips sais pas si
vous imaginez alors on est on est un peu
tôt mais peut-être y aura une sortie
avec les des images avec parce que ça me
remet ça ajoute beaucoup est sûrement
vrai c'est très vite enfin 500 ajouté
vraiment même moi j'ai conçu un peu les
chansons comme des dessins et moi
j'adore dessiner un dessin on comprend
tout de suite de quoi il s'agit dans un
des clips vous parler de liberté de
l'égalité maternité liberté beaucoup il
était bon que fraternité mon cul et vous
jouer au basket
alors quand j'ai vu ce crime je veux
dire ce qui se vend est-ce qu'il est
aussi bon basket qu'on voit dans le clip
franchement non mais franchement est ce
que c'est truqué ou est ce que c'est
vous qui faites et donc non je
je sais que vous avez été joueur de
basket je suis bien meilleur normalement
que parce que je suis pas d'accord bien
sûr vous êtes le meilleur barça tout
c'est moi je veux pas en rajouter
ah voilà ces ballons de basket mais nous
allons là bas j'ai bien retourné
nous avons le panier ouais et c'est
simple il suffirait pas comme dans le
clip en allant vers l'a vu la distance
et un panier à trois points
ouais ça fait un petit peu je sais pas
demandez pas combien de temps mais
veillent dvd il va aider oui mais il n'y
aura pas besoin d'aidé mais j'espère
bien géré a besoin bon alors voilà un
hoquet 8
s'agirait de frapper de temps
je t'aime pas la vie
vous êtes taper mes jetons
attends pas ça
défini ça continue ak oui tu dois pas
volé alors ce kindle à dorique
semble-t-il ah oui c'est l'occasion pour
un autre invité le revenir sur un sujet
d'actualité sur lequel il a envie de
pousser une gueulante ou simplement de
s'exprimer non mais moi j'ai choisi
chirac les
emploi
effectif et
le jugement dernier
gardez jugement qui va les jugements
avant sortie d'autoroute
voilà ça ça et donc je
je t'ai très inquiet et là dessus
qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète non ce qui
m'inquiète c'est de passer devant ces
appartements de voir toujours deux flics
vous parlez quai voltaire quand on
évolue
le pont de saint de fric qu'ils sont là
quand même en permanence pensé à eux
partial
je pense à vue soit en train de regarder
un délinquant
c'était extraordinaire donc cesser la
france est ainsi fait voilà alors là ça
c'est l'ancien professeur de gymnastique
qui va presque vous avez été pour
déposer les 94 organes avant 92 92
alors donc ce coup de sifflet c'est
notre police des arts et nous nous
sortons une vilaine critique pour notre
habitude auquel il va pouvoir répondre
alors allée du 21 octobre fo dada vrai
d'hadès et de sébastien le fol et c'est
dans le figaro du samedi 2 octobre 2010
la marque de fabrique de catherine c'est
le n'importe quoi pourquoi pas
icône kitsch du courant régressive en
vogue actuellement
il promeut l'esthétique du pipi caca
propos certains le considèrent pourtant
comme l'artiste le plus libre de son
époque ne n'eut-il pas liberté mon cul
égalité mon cul fraternité mon cul ou
encore je suis la reine d'angleterre et
je vous chie à la raie que ses
thuriféraires se replonge dans les
dessins satiriques du journal hara kiri
et il se rend donc compte de la banalité
et du conformiste de leurs animateurs
pour pyjama party
j'imagine des gosses sur la pochette du
disque il pose avec ses parents allaient
philippe remettent à tétines eva pauly
c'est ce que conseille sébastien le feu
alors pas ça se conclut très bien
alors vrai confort alors vous me parliez
tout à l'heure de bon une époque
la critique ne s'étendait pas autant sur
mon cas est ce qu'on film katyn sans que
la critique a changé par panneaux mais
c'est à dire que moi je ne me sens pas
du tout dans la peau d'un provocateur
oui vous dites moi je n'ai pas
d'hara-kiri pas envie de ça j'ai envie
de
il est du plaisir d'émotion c'est ça une
émotion en fait j'ai envie de libérer
mon angoisse
il part donc
mais c'est pas ça passe pas par la
provocation
c'est vrai que vous écrivez des chansons
sans hier que vous jetez que vous n'osez
pas ah bah oui quand je pense quand je
me dis ça va ça va faire de la peine
quelqu'un ou des gens te pètes des
chansons aussi ils viennent d'un mauvais
sentiments c'est à dire la rancoeur
ressentiment là dans votre histoire
personnelle oui aussi où ça peut ça peut
déborder de partout non et donc quelque
chose me déplaît à ce moment là encore
quand on attaque directement donc je
suis pas du tout un polémiste suis pas
une grande gueule
je ne m'inscris pas du tout dans canton
n'importe quoi je mange
je
je peux avoir cette impression dès fois
de faire n'importe quoi mais
c'est après en mettant le buzz à
l'endroit j'arrive à saisir quelque
chose mais bon
je me lèverai pas le matin avec l'idée
qu'on enregistre n'importe quoi est
construite la gueule des gens
bon je resterai au lit là vous avez la
caméra dans la main c'est l'occasion
pour notre invité de nous emmener dans
un anecdotes souvenirs personnels enfin
quelque chose qui vous avez mal à l'aise
avec une caméra à lézinnes j'ai fait le
mec une fois et ça m'a
c'était pour ce fils de se trouve
extraordinaire la peau de cochon le
court en référence à votre opération du
coeur et d'ailleurs il ya dans ce film
est d'ailleurs vous savez ce que vous
suiviez aussi votre compagne et savent
où me faisait fantasmer souvenez vous la
suivez dans mon cas ça c'est un
ça c'est un problème personnel que j'ai
quelques jalousies
non non le voyeurisme le confesse
l'astra du comment mais j'aime j'aime
voir sans être vu
ce qui est en ce moment on n'est pas
tout à fait mon ma situation là on se
cache donc j'aime me cacher derrière les
rideaux observer mes voisins à loisir
j'ai pas mal de repères dans paris je
peux observer des gens
je suis un voyeur et en même temps on
dit j'ai l'impression d'être un grand
metteur en scène que je suis dans un
film et que je suis le metteur en scène
de tous à belgrade de progresser sur
canton
quand on tient la caméra on est là c'est
chez vous qui tient la caméra vous
choisissez
quelque chose de très précis je sais pas
ce que c'est mais narines vous emmène et
en cela vous recréez le monde pour vous
êtes la main de dieu là parce que vous
avez vous fait un zoom soir mes narines
voilà c'est ce que se propose second
crise d'ego que vous êtes un acteur des
narines
mais en tant qu'acteur je vais beaucoup
agi sur lennar étrangers une émotion
c'est d'abord les narines au lieu de
pleurer
ça s'est joué sur l'émotion
ce court métrage c'est un court métrage
de gaston kerven sébastien rost bien sûr
y'a yolande moreau
à l'intérieur ça pour le résumer ce
serait comme si c'était rocher un élève
n 1 c'est un fric-frac un cambriolage un
coup monté avec des handicapés et vous
allez voir c'est d'une extraordinaire
tendresse regardez le et vous me direz
ce que vous en pensez j'en serai voilà
vous n'en serez et nous nous en serons
tous autour de ce cd catherine par
philippe katerine c'est chez barclay et
vous serez en tournée dans toute la
france à partir du 3 l'abandon moi c'est
bien ça oui je crois que c'est ça et le
7 décembre vous saurez vous que vous
soyez pas lu quatre aides en tout cas
merci beaucoup c'est un plaisir
[Musique]